hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
looking for evidence-based oncology
try no do targeted proteomics this
webinar is part of the cancer
research and oncology virtual event and
i'm susie valdez of lab roots and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and sponsored by luminex for
more information about luminex
go to www.luminxcorp.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational and
offers continuing education credits
click on the continuing
education credits tab located on the top
right hand corner
of your presentation window and follow
the process to obtain those credits
without further ado i now present
today's speaker
dr christian regenbrook he is the ceo
of the cell phonomics and the ceo of asc
oncology for a complete biography of our
speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
dr rickenbrick welcome you may now begin
your presentation sir
thank you very much for the kind
introduction and the invitation to
present today
so also thank you to all the listeners
and viewers
in the times of corona that you're still
interested in cancer
because nevertheless cancer is still an
important disease
working around the corner so today i'm
talking about
our approach to personalized oncology
and what was fueling it is an interview
by james watson in the new york times
2016
james watson said locating the genes
that cause cancer
has been remarkably unhelpful the belief
that sequencing your dna is going to
extend your life
is a cruel illusion and i totally agree
with it
today politicians doctors
the broader audience they also always
see
personalized medicine as sequencing the
cancer genome and
why this has been unhelpful in the past
is very
well summarized in a paper um
from 2017 in cancer research reviews
by amy brooks and let me just talk you
through it
so our mental cartoon is
that we have a cancer where a normal
cell
receives a mutation or a set of
mutations
develops a new cancer phenotype and
this new cancer phenotype could be
investigated as a mechanistical role
in the signaling pathways of the cells
for example with the ras pathway it's a
very well studied pathway
each and every player was known and
understood
understood so the consequence of therapy
was that people started developing
targeted therapies
against the apparent proteins and the
idea was
if the protein is targeted well then the
cell should go
into apoptosis but the biological
reality
is much more vague because we have
plasticity here heterogeneity
meaning that within the same tumor there
are different clones existing in there
but also on the same genomic background
just in the context of tissue
you have more resistant cells and more
sensitive sets and this is a dynamic
process
and with sequencing for example you only
see
a snapshot you can only see what is
happening at a certain time
you cannot follow this biological
dynamics
so based on that this means that
targeted therapies
have cells that are going into apoptosis
and are targeted well and you have
surviving cells that are stress-induced
cancer stem cells and this also explains
why
second or third line treatment usually
is
less beneficial to the patient when the
first line treatment
so cancer has
various genomic
mutations underlying it and
the treatment is more or less the same
depending on
where the cancer is and which grade and
stage it is and it is only now that we
start to understand that vascular trials
based on
the same underlying molecular events
are needed more eventually than the
location
in the site of the tumor and that means
that
in average for solid cancers
about 50 of the patients benefit from
the first line therapy
only 12.5 percent from a second line
therapy
and from third line therapy 3.75
so this is just an estimate but it shows
very well
the earlier the patient receives the
right treatment
the better it is
so we are not going to design new drugs
but our ultimate goal is to use the
arsenal of weapons
that we have for fighting the war on
cancer we want to bring the right drug
to the right patient at the right time
and how we do that
so we use cell culture models that we
derive
freshly from surgical specimen that we
receive
and they're currently like two
main areas in the field of 3d cycles
one is mechanical force models so-called
steroids
that is like hanging drop technology or
ultra low attachment plates
where the cells have to grow together
just by the sheer forces
of of the droplet
and i always compare that to
cantaloupes grown in cubic glasses this
is not
the biology of a melon this is
forced just by the surrounding
what we and other groups are focusing on
is 3d scaffold so-called organoid models
and here we have the
three-dimensionality
and the mechanical properties with the
chemical complexity
which ultimately leads to a native
organization
and this degree of organization is so
good
that it really mimics the original tumor
hence tumor organoid what you see here
is on the left side spheroid on the
right side an organoid
both derived from the same patient
tissue
and i think you can easily see that this
looks more like a mosaic
and this on the right side the organoid
has a much
more structured domain-like appearance
and how good is this in reality
what you see here in the top row is
tumor tissue from colorectal cancer
as used by the pathologist for
determining the diagnosis
and here is the 3d psychiatric derived
from
the original tissue and even if you're
not a pathologist i think it's easy and
convincing
to see that these patterns look very
much
like the pattern of the upper row
so that is how we see it
if you look at such an organoid under
the microscope you see a
structure which first of all seems like
a lamp of tissue
but if we do stainings with proteins
like adrene or affecting
do an overlay you see this tube like
structure going
through this organite in the next slide
i'm
trying to present to you if the video is
running yep
um how a 3d
z-stack works through such an uh colon
organoid
and you can see like crypt-like
structures here
and we like structures here uh going
into that so this is a highly
ordered structure where a pathologist
would
uh be able to tell you okay this looks
like a colon cancer
uh in fact we did not only do that for
colon cancers
but we were able to do that also for
breast cancers
did a little blinded experiment where we
derived from
five different patients five different
organoid cultures
and send it back to the pathologist and
he was able to map
the right model to the right patient
just based on morphology
expression of markers and so on so we
have reliable
faithfully recreating our models
recreating
the original donor tissue so
from that how do we get closer to the
patient
we do cytotox screenings with those
models
for this together with colleagues from
eli and lily
we have developed a platform for
screening
3d organoid cultures in brief
we pre-culture the organoids
disintegrate them and then we use a
liquid changing station
to use the single sec suspension
and put it in a 384 well
member plate sorry then we add the
growth medium
to the plate and while the cells recover
from this procedure
we do an automated serial compound
dilution on the compound plate
and basically we then stem the compound
dilution plate on the assay plate
and then we test for usually around four
days
the cells then we put a cell title glow
on them
cytoglow is an atp dependent essay
and from that we determine
the viability of cells this procedure
has been deemed a best practice approach
and we're quite happy that it has been
acknowledged
as the way to do it and just to show you
one of our first experiments that we did
this was to establish
the assay we used star sparing or
kinase inhibitor just to show
the concentration dependency so we have
here
the relative luminescence units we have
each single data point concentration of
storage foreign
and if we then calculate from that the
percent inhibition
we see this nice sigmoid curves
representing
um the drug treatment and
the ic50 here around the
50 bar
we can also screen that in a time lapse
video
and what you can see here is an
untreated organoid
growing here again we used store sporing
on different concentrations and it's
easy to see
over time how growth is really inhibited
by the drug in a concentration dependent
matter
so now we have a good model we have a
way to interrogate the model
how do we get close to the patient so
the idea is each drug
has a um c-max
a concentration and maximum
concentration in human blood
and this is specific to each drug and so
we found out which are the c-max values
from investigator brochures oscar
posters etc
applications for
some of those drugs i have depicted it
here
then we have that in milligram per liter
which is unfavorable to use in the cell
culture
so we needed the molecular mass and we
could
recalculate it into micro molar
units something that would suit us very
much in the lab so
with these values we know this is the
maximum amount of
drug that can be solved in human
serum this which is the maximum amount
that theoretically
could reach the tumor meaning this is
our
upper bar for
the drug where it has to reach an ic50
to reach at least
stable disease meaning if we kill 50 of
the cells
and the other cells double in the same
time we have stable disease
so the lower the concentration where we
reach the ic50 is
the better is the predicted outcome for
the patient
let me show to you some practical
examples of that
first of all there is peritoneal
metastases of colorectal cancer
the clinical situation is dire it is a
variant of correct cancer metastasis and
it is
for about 15 of the colorectal cancer
patients
they develop peritoneal metastases and
it's associated with the poor prognosis
surgery is long difficult and for the
patient
um not so easy to take it's a complete
proteomic to me in terms of
chemotherapy there is no guideline
protocol for this tumor entity
meaning people try five of you
irinoticon
oxalic plotting etc etc
some larger hospitals also use high pack
but high pack is associated with high
mobility
definitely not standard here so the
clinical needs for
cancers like that is can we find markers
for patient stratification
or can we identify new targets for an
improved therapy
and what we have um done here
is each diagram represents a specific
drug
so five of you oxalic platinum toxic
taxi
uh sn38 is irinoticon and so on
and each graph in these diagrams
represents
a single patient and you can easily see
that for example here the yellow patient
or the brownish brownish line is the
best responder because it's on the
far left side but for axali platinum
it is the worst responder because it's
on
doesn't even reach the ic50 level so we
cannot even kill half of the cells
and if we go through that you can see
that
basically for each and every patient we
have to find an individual
drug or drug combination that may be
useful and even those two compounds
company zip and ly 29402
work in the same
molecular pathway but on different
targets
and you can see that even there um
patients respond
differently so it is important for us to
know
how the targets are activated and
where the phosphorylation occurs and
these are things
that we cannot learn from sequencing
alone
because that's past translational
modifications and you don't see that
via rna sec and so on
so this is just another representation
of the data i've just shown to you and
it shows you how
wide the the data spread per model and
you can easily identify the best
responses and the worst non-responders
and that gives gives us a good idea and
a good um
way to identify those models that we
want to investigate further
by taking just top three or the lower
three
and test it so that is basically
our our setup for the cell cultures
and now we add another layer of
complexity to it
because as i mentioned before in the
introduction
tumors are heterogeneous and so
what we call reverse clinical
engineering is trying to modeling the
intratumor heterogeneity
what does a tumor look like i think most
of you know
we have the one original cell where the
tumor starts from
and from there different clones can
develop on it
the chances increase for multiple clones
with each and every cell division
so with billions of cell divisions in
any metastatic cancer
we have a variety of
clones in there so what we do
is for example here from a colorectal
cancer again
we took a heterogeneous tumor received
from the pathologist
five distinct regions we cultivated each
and every
region of this tumor
into the drug screening and don't worry
i don't go through all of the grafts now
but what i want to show you is for
example here in azd8931
there's an up to 30-fold difference
between
the different regions of the same tumor
at the same time and
for me this was a eureka moment it was a
eureka moment because i always ask
myself
why in the 21st century the personal
treatment in colorectal cancer is still
a systemic chemotherapy
and now i understand that it's due to
the intra-tumor heterogeneity
with the systemic chemotherapy you
reduce
the amount of clones in the tumor
making it more likely that on the
furious
survival survival clones
the drug really works and i think that
is
an enormous understanding at least was
for me
in how to treat and handle those tumors
so what we did then next uh was we
did a transduction antiviral transaction
with
the resistant in the susceptible
population
in green and red we mixed them
and injected them into animals
so what we see here is we started the
treatment
and here's the treatment stop about 46
day
after implantation which is quite a long
time
and you see that this um
hyperonimus the control and pectivisip
we had to sacrifice the animals because
the tumors were growing
very quickly but with all the other
drugs
we were able to keep the tumor burden in
chest
so and then we stopped the treatment and
did a long follow-up
and what you can see here is that each
single drug or combination the tumors
grew back
except for the combinations it took them
up
plus regrouping and that was very
interesting
because the patient was um white
i was uh rust mutated and situximab has
only an approval
uh for white type or harass patients
in colorectal cancer so when we try to
publish
this data we were asked by reviewer
three
hey why do you try cetoxin up at all
the patient would never receive it in
the clinic
and the answer to that is quite simple
we tried it because we can we have the
ability to screen in a 384
format in a way that
we can try out things without
putting the patient's life and health at
risk
and as you see here they took them up
alone
didn't work as expected but
neither did rigorous nip only the
combination of these two
was highly effective effective in this
patient
and i think this is the approach that
that we want to go
i was asked where i wanted to present
and i said i want to
present in the disparity session why was
that
because i think every cancer patient is
a disparity
when compared to a large cohort and we
have to go
back to the focus of the individual
so the next thing that we
we then did is we took our
pdx tumors did some
labeling with them we found the gfp and
cherry
cells we merged them and what we saw is
they existed side by side
they existed not intermixed
but side by side as regions and that is
again very much closely to the organoids
as compared
to the spheroids we did some faxing
and um we found that there were tumors
with a low
and cherry population compared to a
high-end cherry population
and we tried to map that and um this is
a quick representation of what we found
in the control cell and control animals
about
eighty percent of the cells were green
and twenty percent red
the tumors were shrinking a little bit
when treating with stromatinib
but green cells became more favorable
took them up alone basically did not
shrink the tumor
but still the selection was a little bit
preferring in the green cells
but for example when tweaking with
traumatic plus it took some up
tumors got very small and consisted of
about 75 percent red cells
what does that mean that means in a
clinical from a clinical perspective
the tumor was shrinking one would
suggest the treatment is working
but what we saw is it was selecting for
the more aggressive population
the right one and with the more
aggressive population
this easily explains why second or third
line treatment
will be harder to
have positive results for the patients
so
that is i think very nice and um
experiment to show the biology of these
things
and now we add a third omics layer and
it's a targeted proteomics approach
called gtwest
developed by our friends and colleagues
at the nmi
and this is based on luminex technology
which i think is quite elegant so
what does digi west do you just do a
classical western blot
you do your sds page you plot it on the
membrane
then you cut out the lanes and the bands
you elude the proteins and couple them
to luminex speeds
luminex beads are fluorescence beads
with
specific color coding
and that helps us to do multiplexing
because we can now poo them and know
which color is
associated with which molecular weight
and that helps us to use the amount that
you usually need for a single
western blot to do up to 800 analytes
from one sample in terms of the
organoids
that means from four wells of a 24 well
plate
we are now able to do up to 200 proteins
and phosphor proteins
and this is for me the the
coolest thing about this technology we
see the past translational modification
we see on the proteomic level is the
pathway activated or not and
this is such a benefit for what we are
doing
um but i cannot stress it um enough
so we see here just to show you these
are
sarcoma samples that we have used and
these look
distinctive from other cell types or
nice control we
put mouse liver in there and the system
is so nice
that in fact for the tumor with the
wrecking greens cell populations i
showed you before
we could explain why certain drugs could
not work
and why other drugs had to work
so if we look at the pier 3 kinase enter
axis
we see that it's basically no different
expression or activation from the
surface
down to the transcription factors
so the akt is differently expressed
but on the phosphorylation level it's
the same akg2
the same and so on going downstream
one single experiment so all in parallel
all from the same
sample if we switch over to the map
kinase pathway
we see the receptor level no difference
you see on the ras level no significant
difference
b rough phosphorylation no difference
mech
expression no difference but
then we see the differentiated
phosphorylation
uh it makes one two following down to
erg
p90 rsk so we could see that
and this is linked to an activating
mutation
upstream of mac one two so with the
genomics
we count the activating mutation with
the targeted proteomics
we could explain it and i think this is
um
so awesome for future generation of
patients
that this will help very much sorry this
slide is in german but
so it starts with patient-informed
consent
then biopsy is taken then we have the
classical clinical pathology
with histopathology immune histology
molecular pathology
fish sequencing chromosomal operations
so the standard of care on the right
side we have what aac has to offer
we do the patient-derived 3d cycle
models
we do the in vitro pharmacology
generate a pharmacological profile in
parallel
we have the targeted proteomics
integrate that
and we really uh discuss with the
oncologist
in the tumor boards our data and
compete with the genomic data for the
best solution
for the patients so
because i think it's very important
to to see in which context this works
uh sarcomas are basically the orphans of
oncology
so sarcomas are soft tissue and tumors
and very understudied and
we use them in the cell culture
and we have now an average take rate of
73
as of august 1st and with our new
methods
of cultivating sarcomas you see for
example
some subtypes of these sarcomas we have
up to 100 percent
take rate meaning a tumor entity which
is
totally aggressive that usually hits
um teenagers
young adults harsh chemotherapy
we have now a way to provide those
people which
with crash test dummies where we can
pre-test
which treatment will help or will not
help
here is just some some uh slide to show
how close we are to the situation the
women team
is positive um all the others
uh negative that's mean we find single
cell in the patients positive negative
in the cell culture and key 67 for
proliferation
in the same range of those um
67 expressions so we are very very close
to the clinical situation
here different type of sarcoma
all the cohort of um
markers that we have tested again here
key 67
80 versus 80 to 90 so this
is really close to the patient situation
and if we look at the data from the drug
screening
we can easily see for those tumors
which drugs are favorable and which or
not we have drugs
where we have no response at all
where we have just a flat line not a
curve
but we have drugs that are so effective
in this case storage boring as a
pancreas inhibitor
control cannot be used clinically just
to show you
that is an effective drug
but actiniumizing d for example nice
curve
we reach very early in ic50
and this is something to suggest to the
patients or here
toxic will be seen even at the lowest
concentration we
we administer to the cell culture
already below ic50
and this is from our perspective
very much helping the oncologist to
choose the right drug
within the framework of his guidelines
and also
help the patient not only to accept
and comply to the treatment but also
in the course of treatment many patients
have told us
if we wouldn't have seen the data black
and white
we wouldn't have gone through this pain
of treatment
and here our other sarcoma
patient different a molecular profile
you see here for example doxorubicin
is still working but not as good as
with the others but trobectidine in this
case for the patient works like a charm
so these are the things that we are
working on and
where we think that we bring a hat
on the oncology and reshape the ecology
of the future
and of course i have always the pleasure
of presenting this data and being happy
to show that to you
but as you can see here on that screen
and there's a large team behind it
at the company everybody was working out
especially specifically for the patient
project
we have full support um from companies
like
luminex that help us investigate these
things
thank you very much for that and the
video that you see
here is not a computer animation but
this is
some scanning electron microscopy video
basically it's a stop-motion animation
we did a photo under the
sem moved the stage took the next photo
and so on
and what you see is an organoid of a
colorectal cancer
just to show you that there's also
a kind of beauty in this tumors
thank you very much and i hope i find
some
questions now if i move back to
the presenter stack
thank you
and thank you dr reagan brick for that
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
and if you have any questions you want
to ask please do so now just click on
that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started we have quite a lot
of
questions already coming in
our first question is how do oncologists
respond to your approach
well that totally depends um we have
oncologists in university hospitals that
say okay we know all the stuff and we
know it better
and we have our experience and we don't
anybody
to guide us through our decision making
process
but those people are rare most people
are happy
if we find a way to support them in the
decision making process
and specifically people working in
peripheral clinics or
their own doctor's office are happy that
they're able
um to offer their patients these kind of
services
because that was unimaginable a couple
of years ago that was
top-notch comprehensive cancer center
a level treatment and diagnosis
thank you so much now is it true that
a person who has cancer more than other
people
are in the high risk of covet
now um interesting question i'm not a
physician
but you can easily imagine that with
chemotherapy and all the side effects
um your immune response is
low and with that the risk of um
catching kelvin is very much higher than
with a normal healthy person so
definitely risk group
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience members for these great
questions coming in
um now do you think that crispr will
play a key
role in the fight against cancer
well it will play a key role
in terms of research
because if you can crisper in specific
mutations or crisper them out it helps
enormously
to understand the biology to identify
biomarkers i think we are very
far wasted from using it in the human
body
and really treating the patient with the
crispr
based approach uh but for the research
purposes i think
it's boosting cancer research yes
definitely
thank you dr rogenberg now let's talk
about sarcoma we have an audience member
that wants to know
what causes sarcoma and is it inherited
or is it acquired at some point in life
and if it is inherited what can cause it
well sarcomas are
as i said red humans it's less than 10
of all solid humans
um patients often report
that at the site where the sarcoma
was diagnosed they had a broken bone or
any other injury but it is
more a felt knowledge because
large studies have shown that there is
no correlation
in fact the genomics of sarcomas
looks very different than for carcinomas
in sarcomas you either have very few
mutations
or the genome looks like you have aimed
at it with a shotgun and it's totally
uh corrupt so um
it is definitely a genomic disease um
i would not i do not see any
in direct environmental elements that
play into the role it's
spontaneous mutations and of course
inherited
by the predisposition with those tumor
genes so
often it's fusion genes that you find in
sarcomas more than you would
expect for example in carcinomas
thank you so much dr gumbrecht our next
question
will you need to do some clinical trials
to validate
your method of treatment um
yes and we are currently doing so we are
currently designing a phase four
clinical trial
for sarcomas uh even for first line
treatment patients and
within the german health system we are
currently also
working together with university
hospitals um
to conduct clinical trials on various
tumor entities
together with the tumor boards and for
advanced cancer patients in certain
treatment that
are to today's standard of care beyond
care thank you so much dr rickenbrook
we have time for a couple of more
questions
let's talk about your partners do you
already have clinical partners in place
yes as i just mentioned uh yes we have
some
university hospitals in germany we are
currently working with
but also with clinics in austria
and the uk we work quite closely
and exchange knowledge and patient
tissue
um that are those regular partners
and as i mentioned earlier that
small hospitals every now and then want
to send
samples of their patients to us if they
don't find
a standard of care treatment that really
helps the patient
yes sir we are currently expanding
internationally
thank you very much and actually that is
our last question that we have time for
an audience member wants to know do you
offer the services internationally so
maybe you can expand a little bit on
that
yeah so um the method that that we use
allows us to cultivate tumor tissue
that um needs to be relatively fresh
or meaning with everything within 36
hours
from surgery to our laps we can process
meaning uh the boundaries are more
customs
than the transportation process and
within the eu that is totally no problem
um
it's sometimes especially now in the
times of kelvin gets difficult
if if customs is involved and they don't
process the tissue
quickly enough
thank you so much and actually we have
one more question that just came in
and i think we have some time for it
what are the challenges to design your
clinical trial of dr rigenbrick
um the biggest challenge is
what is the control if you work on a
personalized individualized basis who is
the control
for the patient that we are treating we
don't have
twins that we could use so
the problem is the the way oncologists
and the system thinks it's
in large cohorts and large cohorts just
predict
an average risk but you will not find
any oncologist
that would put a specific patient's
personal
risk on such a graph so
that is something where we need to
change the way of thinking
and to promote the confidence
and that has been done for example by us
and other groups um there's a nice paper
uh from vladimir jarnis in 2018
where they did a co-clinical trial
and with colorectal cancer patients in
100
they predicted correctly which drugs
will not work
and in 88 they predicted correctly which
standard of care drugs will work and i
think
that is an enormous step ahead and that
was the first step opening um the minds
for clinical trials
and being a little bit more um
futuristic doctor
thank you again for your presentation
today and for your time with us
and would you like to provide some
closing remarks for our audience before
we go
yeah so um as i said thank you very much
for
for the interest but um most importantly
if any of you um would like to
collaborate with us
we are happy to do so if you have
patients that you would like to support
in the decision
making decision making process we are
glad if we can help
and every clinic that would like to run
a clinical trial with us
also just approach us the email address
i think is in the cv
dr irgenbrick thank you again for your
time today and for your important
research
and before we go i want to remind the
audience
that today's questions any questions not
answered today and those submitted on
the demand period
will be addressed via speaker and the
contact information you provided
during registration thank you for
joining us and i'd also like to thank
our sponsors illuminix
for sponsoring today's webinar this
webcast
can be viewed on demand for six months
till april of
2021 labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share
this email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event
until next time take care stay healthy
bye-bye bye